the brutal reality of war is contained
in this small lorry
each morning talas and his team head
towards the front line to collect the
bodies of Fallen Ukrainian soldiers and
return them to their families
a Relentless task as Russia's offensive
in the East intensifies
foreign
he hides it well everyone here puts on a
brave face
combat Medics have brought their dead
from the battlefield to this morgue in
the city of kramatosk
each one killed in action
identities are checked and bodies
photographed
this Soldier should have been
celebrating his 27th birthday
carrying the dead home with dignity is
why this unit called on the shield was
formed
[Music]
evidence is clear of the huge price
Ukraine is paying
what is it
commanders don't disclose the total
number of losses but the bodies of more
than 15 soldiers were at this next
morgue in just one morning
with more arriving
those Russian soldiers who are coming in
in the Ukrainian learn more and more it
means that for us the war or the fight
will be more intense in the nearest uh
future
it's a grim certainty and it hangs over
all the teams tasked with retrieving the
dead across the east
foreign
a second unit on the next stage of this
constant process
once away from the front line the bodies
of soldiers are brought to morgues like
this one where forensic experts will
examine them establish the cause of
death before they're then sent onto
their final Journey to the families
where they'll then be buried
for the body collectors though
it's a journey that keeps on repeating
Deborah Haynes Sky News in eastern
Ukraine